مرحبا بكم بقى قالت الشرطه الفرنسيه انها
اعتقلت 11 شخصا خلال اشتراكات ان اسفرت عن
اصابه 31
بين قوات الامن ومحتاجين على الهجوم الذي
ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من الجاليه
الكرديه في باريس يوم الجمعه وكشف مصدر
مقرب من التحقيقات ان المجتبه به في تنفيذ
الهجوم اكد انه ارتكب الاعتداء لدى واقعه
عنصريه بينما الغت النيابه العامه قرار
احتجازه لاسباب الصحيه واحالته الى الطبيب
النفسيه ورد ان عاد الانتقادات بشان عدم
توصيف الجريمه بانها ارهابيه قال وزير
العدل الفرنسيه ان هناك فرقا بين الجريمه
العنصريه والجريمه الارهابيه
اعلنت الاداره العسكريه لمدينه خريصون
جنوبيه اوكرانيا عن مقتل 10 اشخاص وجرح 55
اخرين في تجدد القصف الروسيه على احياء
عده في المدينه فقال وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان بلاده قادره على منع مثل هذه
العمليات اذا حصلت على اسلحه النوعيه
بدورها وصفت السفيره الامريكيه في
اوكرانيا هجوم الروسيه على اخر صوم الوحشي
لروسيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت
احياء سكنيه في المقاطعه وبثت لقطات لما
قالت انها تدمير نقطه مراقبه اوكرانيه في
منطقه
الشرقيه البلاد
اضرب عشرات الالاف من عمال السكك الحديديه
في انجلترا وويلز عن العمل للمطالبه
بتحسين ظروف العمل وزياده الاجور ومن
المقرر ان تطال الاضرابات ايضا السائقين
الحافلات في جنوب وغرب لندن لمده 11 يوما
خلال يناير كانون الثاني المقبل هذا
واستعانه السلطات البريطانيه بقوه من
الجيش للقيام بعمل موظف الجوازات في
ثمانيه مطارات اضافه الى قطاعات اخرى تشهد
اضرابات من العاملين فيها
في فرنسا نفذ السائقون والمراقبون والعمال
عن العمل للمطالبه بتحسين اوضاعهم ورفع
اجورهم وقالت شركه السكك الحديديه
الفرنسيه حوالي نصف رحلات القطارات
السريعه الغيت بسبب الاضراب
في الولايات المتحده لقي مالا يقل عن 19
شخص نصرهم نتيجه العاصفه الثلجيه
المتواصله التي تضرب البلاد وتسببت في
انخفاض القياسيا لدرجات الحراره
اكثر من 1000 و500 رحله طيران كما ادت الى
القطاعات في التيار الكهربائي والتعطل في
خطوط النقل على الساحل الشرقي ومنطقه
البحيرات العظمى
اوقفتم منظمه انسانيه دوليه اعمالها في
افغانستان من بينها المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين والمعونه الافغانيه البريطانيه
بين معلقت اللجنه السويديه لافغانستان
عملياتها مؤقتا في عموم البلاد وذلك
احتجاجا على قرار الحكومه منع عمل النساء
في المؤسسات غير الحكوميه الاجنبيه
والمحليه الخاصه